NATO countries have yielded into a
barrage of demands from President Trump
at their summit in Brussels Belgium the
president told reporters just a short
time ago that NATO allies will speed up
increases in defense spending after he
told them he was quote extremely unhappy
with their commitment to the military
alliance the president claims NATO is
now stronger than it was before the
summit and other leaders say they in the
US are still united major Garrett
attended the president's news conference
and he's with us from Brussels major
good morning good morning it's been a
very hectic couple of hours here at NATO
headquarters the NATO spokesman said
there was a special meeting called those
in the room told wire service reporters
it was an emergency meeting the topic
the future of NATO defence spending and
around it veiled threats from the
president I states that the United
States might withdraw from NATO though
that was never explicitly mentioned but
clearly President Trump was prevailed
upon by his staff and those here to talk
about the enduring strength of the NATO
alliance and he took credit rushing to
the microphones to say his advocacy for
accelerated defense spending turned the
time they really stepped up their
commitment and stepped it up like they'd
never had before NATO now is really a
fine-tuned machine people are paying
money that they never paid before
they're happy to do it and the United
States is being treated much more fairly
the United States commitment to NATO is
very strong remains very strong but
primarily because everyone the spirit
they have the amount of money they're
willing to spend the additional money
that they will be putting up has been
really really amazing
the president said 33 billion dollars in
additional defense spending was
committed to last year he said more is
coming the president also said that
until he became president NATO spending
was going down that's not true starting
in 2014
non-us NATO defence spending has been
increasing each and every year that's
something negotiated by President Obama
nevertheless president Trump's lobbying
has accelerated that trend something the
president took credit for here in
Brussels Norah there
a great deal of relief and many of the
members there as the president
reaffirmed NATO's importance what did
the president say about this upcoming
summit and meeting with Russian
President Vladimir Putin well he glossed
over something I've detected here in
Brussels Nora which is a bit of anxiety
among European leaders about what may or
may not happen when President Trump sits
down with Vladimir Putin in Helsinki on
Monday the president said no one here is
anxious about his meeting look forward
to it said they thanked him for sitting
down with Vladimir Putin president also
again asked his Russia friend or foe or
an enemy of the United States president
said Russia is a competitor hopes to get
along well you said it's an open-ended
loose meeting with no firm agenda
possible conversations about Syria and
Ukraine but the president quite clearly
trying to minimize expectations heading
to Helsinki Nora all right major thank
you